仏教における悪魔の誘惑
理論的に成り...成立できない概念
悪魔っていうことは理論的に成立できないんです
しかし 仏教はその単語を使います
なぜならば自分が主なんですよ
生命は自分で知って生きてるから
すべて自己責任なんです
私は賞味期限切れたものを食べたら
私がそう食べたんだから
私の責任なんです 仕事が忙しくて食べることできなかったんだ
だから会社のせいだと言ったっても
そうはならない 痴は愚痴ですが
誰かが自分を騙して真理を隠しているものではありません
あの愚痴の問題持ってきたでしょ？見てもねつ造して合成するんだと
自分やっているんだからね
もし誰かサンガ来て もう呪いやってマジックをやってないものをあるように見せたならば
その人のせいなんです
そうじゃないんです 世の中にある音やら見えるものやら
味わうものやら 私は見て味わって聞いてるんです
そうすると私がそれはねつ造して合成して愚痴にするんです
だから自分がやってるんです
誰かが騙され騙そうとしてないんです
花が私は美しいんだそうと言って
詐欺やって騙させてるわけじゃないんです
花はそのままあるだけ
それ見てなんて綺麗だと思って心に問題を作るのは私なんです
因果律は生命の自然の法則なので
生命と自然 両方の法則です
なので 因縁を変えて結果を変えることは可能です
だから因果法則でしょうね
だから因縁を変えてみれば結果が変わります
不幸な結果 嫌だな 嫌なら
虫でいるのは嫌なら 奴隷でいるのは嫌なら
自由になりたいという結果があるならば
我々やらなくちゃいけないことは
この因果法則を変えなくちゃいけない
すべて無常だから いくらでも変えられます
いくらでもというわけじゃないんだけど
因果法則によって変えることはできます
愚痴だからできないだけです
愚痴ですから これが原因とわからないんです
だからもう苦しいんでだけでお金があればなんとか幸せに楽にやれますよね
変なことを考える そうすると金儲けに行く
でもそれで苦しみは消えるわけじゃないんです
そういうわけで人間幸福になりたいと頑張ってますけど
この愚痴で考えて頑張ってるんだから
まずその期待する結果出てこない
大金持ちになりたいと思っても
自分が思うほどはなりません
もし因果法則がしっかり金持ちになる道歩んだならば
金持ちになれますけど
それが理解できません
すごい頭がいい 頭きれいをしっかりした人間になりたいと思うならば
それなりに因果法則を変えなくちゃいけないんです
しかし 原因発展するのも愚痴で発展してるでしょう
だからできなくなっているんです
因果法則だけならもう簡単に変えられます
問題はこれ 発展できないしということなんです
だから自分が主ということで
悪魔にそんな権利ないんです
苦しみに陥っている自分自身の悪魔が自分自身ですよ
苦しみに陥っている我々は生きています
悩んで生きています 失望感で生きています
もうすごいいろいろあります
それが自分なんですよ
自分が主なので 自分がやっているんです
完全たる幸福に達した自分自身が絶対的神
あるいは神を乗り越えたものになるんです
だから悪魔も自分です
自分自身で苦しみを作っています
誰かが自分で苦しみを作ることをやめて
愚痴を正知に変えたならば
一切苦しみ消えちゃうんです
貪瞋痴はたちまち消えちゃうんです
煩悩も消えちゃうんです
だってそれは一時的な幻覚だから消えます
そうなってくると 神も乗り越えたことになってますよ
もう神です だからお釈迦様は自分がブラフマだよ
ブラフマっていうのは自分のことであると堂々とおっしゃった
ブラフマっていうのは
当時のインドの言葉で絶対的神様に使う単語なんです
時々ブラフマなんかは私にはもうかなわないんだと
もう全部乗り越えているんだと
余裕です だからあの人に怒られたでしょ
お釈迦様がお釈迦様がこの悟り開いて
時間も お釈迦様も何も召し上がらないで
フォーティナインデイズ時間四十九日目でご飯食べたんですけどね
それ断食とか何とかじゃないんです
ただ悟りに達したんだから
すごいやっちゃったんですよ
すごいことを もう生命初めて
だからもうすごいことだから
想像を絶するということだから
その喜びでずっと禅定に入っていたんです
場所を変えながら まあそれからいくらなんでも肉体には栄養あげなくちゃいけないんだから
まあご飯食べ始めて それから説法だけは誰もしないぞと決めてまったし
それでも説法するしなさいとね
言われて では誰に言おうかなと思ったら
自分の友達に説法するんだと思って
まあヴィパッサナーというような方を見て歩いたんですね
結構やりまして 途中でこのある人
ウパカという人に会うんですよ
会ったらお釈迦様を見たら
なんかまあ なんかすごい違ってます
人間っていうのはいろいろ色形があるし
やりたいことはいっぱいあるし
だからもう誰見たってもなんかもう
すごいもう壊れなんか壊れてる
何か機械みたいにもうみんな音だったり
生きてるんです 穏やかじゃないんです
お釈迦様だけ もう体見たくても
なんか全然なんか何もやることはもうないという仕事を完了している
この穏やかさ感じるんですね
本人がものすごい今 家で喧嘩したりして
なんかかなりの悩みもあったんです
奥さんがなんかすごい性格悪かったみたいです
この人も仕事をしないんで
家にいるだけ だから毎日毎日奥さんに殴られる
それで子供をあやす場合
場合も奥さんがあの怠け者の子供は泣かないでくれと歌うんだそうです
だからなんかすごい立場がわで
すごく綺麗に歌うんだそうです
怠け者の子供は泣かないでくれとか
まあ歌いながら子供を
それでもうもうもういられなくなっちゃって
もう腹が立って出て行ったんです
出たとこでお釈迦様にあったんです
あったら この差がね ものすごいんです
それでもうあなたすごい落ち着いてますけど
師匠は誰ですか？というのも
いきなりね 私でね 師匠
いません 私は自分で一人で真理発見する
それで今一切のこと知っていますよ
だから自分ですべてのことを知り尽くした私には
師匠なんかいるわけないでしょう
だからすごい態度 でっかい言葉なんですよ
だから彼も嫌み言おうと思って
あんたなんか一切勝利者みたいな感じで喋ってますよと
もうあなたにはもう勝てる人はいないというと
誰にも打ち勝っているような感じで言ったらと嫌味ったんです
嫌みとお釈迦様 その通りであると
まあディサーウェイディナー本って勝利者といえば私のことであるというふうにまた歌うんですよ
そちらでこのすべてのものを知って
一切のことを知り終えて
やるべきことを全部成し終えて
心は完全に自由にしている自分ということをはっきりと
もう神々に乗り越えているんだということを言ってます
だから 時と場合によってお釈迦様は堂々と言う時もあります
だからそれもお釈迦様自身であったことで
我々は自分の責任で悪魔になっている
もし我々には自分の責任で悪魔をやめて神になることもできます
同じ人物だと思っておいてください
悪魔といっても神といっても同じものである
それは自分のことなんです
だから心入れ替えるだけで悪魔が神になるという
この場合は悪魔神って
私はただ象徴的な単語を使いますから
別に悪魔様 神様ではなくて
人格化をしたものではなくで
この概念だけを使ってみて
自分が悪魔なんです それで自分の愚痴をやめちゃうと
もう神なんです 私の妄想思考は悪魔である
思考に感情に誘惑されて生きていると理解することは仏教の立場です
だから仏教の立場っていうのは
本当に悪魔というのは手が悪魔ですよということじゃないんです
悪魔の私の右足だよとかね
私の胃袋が胃袋が悪魔ですよとかね
そんなことじゃないんです
そんなのはどうたどうったことないんですね
私の妄想思考ですよ それで生きてるんだからね
妄想して喋る 妄想して見る
妄想していろんなことをやるという
だからそれが悪魔なんです
一生懸命大事に考えてるのは誰ですかね
やめなさいと言っているのに
思考はやめないでしょう
何としてでも妄想する
同じことを繰り返して繰り返す
大したことでもない  すごい幅広く立派なことをするならば
それでも面白い それでもない
ほんのね ほんのちょこっとのこと
そればっかり だから悪魔っていうのは
その妄想思考が悪魔なんです
そういうふうに理解するんです
仏教は はい 次に問題は
じゃあ私の妄想が悪魔であるならば
周りには関係ないのかということもないんですね
結局はすべてが因縁によって現れる現象なので
独立した存在ではありません
私は因縁だから独立じゃないんです
だから私の心も独立していないんです
いろんな因縁によって生まれるんです
だから 例えば自分の心を汚すこと
喜ばせること 恐怖感に襲われることっていうのは
とても簡単にできます
例えば ものすごい自分
いろんな美しいものを見ると
心が勝手に喜んだりする
そちらの影響で何か見たらすごく怖くなったりする
見ただけなんですよ だからこう生きていると
目から情報入るわ 耳から情報入るわ
体にいろんなものを触れるわ
それで心がくったくた変化していくんです
という それが因果法則ということで
因縁によりというコンディショナルということになります
だから自分の心もコンディショナルだから
周りの影響は何のことなく受けます
受けて心は変化する だから私が悪魔ですと言っても
周りの誘惑ないわけじゃないんです
自分も独立していないのです
自分の妄想思考を外からの情報影響によって作ったり変えたりもする
だから考えることは変えたりするでしょ
後で 外の情報なんですね
必ず周りからの誘惑があるが
それに従うのは自分ということにもなる
誘惑はありますけど それにすぐ飛んで入り込むのは自分なんです
だから微妙なんです 自分が悪魔でしょうし
周りに誘惑されるでしょうし
誘惑を飲み込むのは自分なんです
だから周りが悪いということだけは言ってはならないし
言えないし 特に例えばお釈迦様はこう言いますよ
美しい山やら環境やら
世の中の美しいものは何も悪いことはありません
それに関わるあなたの心に起こる欲望
束縛が問題である それが環境に
自然に対してはそれでいいんです
しかし 人間同士でそうじゃないんですね
人間が強引にいろんなことをさせようとしているんです
みんなアホだから 自分しか世の中にないでしょ
自分の思考は自分だけだからね
他の人と別な思考なんです
自分の思考と同じものにさせてやれよというありえないことに頑張っているんです
だから仲間作るんですよ
いろんなことの仲間 いろんな目的があって
なんとかの仲間 なんとかの仲間
なんとかなクラブとか
なんとかなんとかクラブ作っても同じにはならないんです
それからもう学校 大学なんかはクラブ作ったら朝から晩までクラブでいなくちゃいけない
勉強は禁止です 授業ありますよ
授業に行ったらあんたどうするの？今
いや 今日もうすごい大変ですよ
もうよっぽどおかしいんですよ
それでなんで学生はクラブ作るのかというと
やっぱり同じことで 自分と似ている意見の人々と交流したい
コミュニケーションを取りたいと
取れないんですよ コミュニケーションなんて
それぞれ一人一人違いますから
はい そういうことで この周りの人間の誘惑っていうのは結構大変です
自己管理っていうのはなかなか大変なんです